[Music]
there is a company
that is willing to offer more than six
thousand dollars
if you will smell dog [ __ ] for two
months
hell is the company freaking
jackass
how long are we waiting for six
because i've done that before what do
you mean how long it doesn't say how you
think this is how long
you gotta put your nose in it you gotta
wait 35 like it's fear factor
wait what do you mean you've done it so
i had three dogs at one point and i had
a small backyard and they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] all day so you could clean up
the backyard and there's [ __ ] tons of
[ __ ] in one day already and it's just
constant so we just left one of the
windows closed
but as soon as you go outside you smell
it so i'm pretty used to it i think oh i
always like it when my dog would [ __ ]
and then there's like a bunch of hair in
it it's like my girlfriend's hair and
i'm like you ate hair
absolute [ __ ] happened in here so you
would do this challenge i think you
could do i would i think what's the end
goal of that yeah they're like recurring
health problems though like you know
what i mean what happens at the end of
the month how much does it against six
thousand six years yeah six days for how
long about two months for two months
without and you can't do anything else
for two months you guys are just
smelling dogs are you just living with
it or you know what they're doing so
they're doing it's called this company
is called omni okay they they specialize
in plant-based dog food they're
basically saying hey we want we want a
dog owner to be dedicated to sniffing
the dog's poo poo in order to to um test
the effect that a plant-based diet has
in the dog's digestion the odor and the
health yeah that's actually pretty cool
that's not bad dog [ __ ] is really
colorful
because you can go from like white to
brown sometimes it's like mustard yellow
it's pretty cool you amaze me every time
you say something
like just like the the sentences you put
together i wouldn't expect you because
it's very colorful yeah like human
shit's pretty colorful sometimes too
right you just don't stare at it at all
it does have a lot of variety though see
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah human [ __ ] has variety too i don't
know you guys are i think we just don't
have to scoop the human [ __ ] so we don't
think about it i've never had a uh
mustard yellow dookie in my toilet
that's true i've never seen the mustard
yellow one except for out of dogs have
you ever had green green dookie i like
green dookie oh yeah yeah definitely red
little shop
you smile when you say that i don't know
shabu shabu without rice that makes it
green yeah you just get all greens and
meat you remember those caramel apple
pops dude
[ __ ] in green for days which one
remember the ones it's like it's like
covered in caramel and it has green
inside of it oh [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
green for a week though you ever eat
beets and then see your [ __ ] the next
day it looks like you bled your [ __ ]
intestines that's bad dude yeah that's
bam yeah you know what my favorite dog
[ __ ] prank was of old days
when you when everyone runs out to the
basketball court to play and then you
get the ball and you just put in some
dog [ __ ]
and then you just go all right guys game
on you throw it the first guy gets it
classic they start passing around and
they just go what the [ __ ] man
i love that
i love it
why did every kid do that dude every
school nobody ever trusted me if i'm the
first one out there like man we're gonna
be able to have a ball recess and [ __ ]
and then you're in the water fountain
trying to [ __ ] wash off the dog [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] you riot
dog [ __ ] pranks with a z dude
i'll never forget when i when i lived in
koreatown uh my buddy at the time he's a
[ __ ] wild man
uh
so this guy we're pulling into a parking
spot parking in that area is a [ __ ]
nightmare right and we always let my
chick park in the structure so i
couldn't get a spot and we're circling
forever finally a spot opens up we're
turning in and this guy just bolts in
[ __ ] parks there right what a
[ __ ] we had we had a we had some
panic express in the car and [ __ ]
so we finally we go like nine blocks
away park we'll walk all the way out
right
he just sits there in my in my apartment
he's [ __ ] stewie but he just sits
there and orderly like eats his panda
express then he he doesn't say anything
to me he just goes into the bathroom
okay he brings his panda express bag
into the bathroom
he takes a [ __ ] into the bag the bag oh
[ __ ] and then he's he's like you want to
come outside with me and i'm like
what's going on he's like come on let's
go outside and i was like all right well
because the neighbor was kind of bad so
i was alright you didn't smell anything
fishy
now
so we go outside it's got this warm bag
with me he walks all the way to that car
and he [ __ ] takes the bag he flips it
over and he [ __ ] dumps his [ __ ] on
their hood that's dope
that's [ __ ] baller and honestly that
is a wild man it's a wild man that's
poetic justice though i think that's
what they got deserved he was like dude
it was that car that's my car man
like it's dark dude always coming
someone walks up and like who put
cockney on my hood man
i didn't deserve this he falls to his
knees
i like to think that that guy walked out
and he never even noticed the dog [ __ ]
like ever
yeah the punishment fits the crime on
that one like just rolls right off the
hood and he just drives like and it
rains at night
there's this guy that uh used to rent
from my mom's house and he's like one of
these guys where like you look at him
and you're like
you kind of want to bully him
and you know you know this guy's been
bullied his whole life your bully bone
goes off he's been bullied his whole
life and you want to bully him yeah
when you see it when you see him you're
like okay yeah i know what you're
talking about
um so because so one of the things he
does is he likes to wash his car in the
driveway right but before he washes his
car in the driveway he'll take like
grocery bags like this
and then he'll put it on his shoes like
shower caps hmm nice so that his shoes
don't get wet what a [ __ ] yeah he
should be like either you just wear
sandals or you go barefoot or i don't
know just just don't do that right but
that's crazy just don't do that afraid
of water bud but that's the stuff that
he would do that who gets those hair
shower caps and puts it on his shoes and
[ __ ] and walks around the house and i
would i would uh so i helped manage my
mom's rental property and this guy would
literally call me every single month
that people are rubbing [ __ ] all over
his car
and i'm like what the [ __ ] what are you
gonna do he's just flipping like what
you're going to do and i'm like nothing
i'm like you call the cops i don't even
live around here and every single month
i think just because the way he looked
or the way he acted
all the kids on the street were like
[ __ ] this guy why i don't know he's just
so weird this guy installed a [ __ ]
rear view mirror on his back of the
[ __ ] van you know the kind that's
like the arm so and the face is down so
that the mirror so your rear view mirror
can see that mirror can see this guy's
an [ __ ] he's also one of those guys
that has a steering wheel thing that has
a circular thing on here so you can grab
it so that you can just turn it
i thought if you're like if you have
like a disability you can use it do you
think he has disabilities no he bought
it at the [ __ ] sanrio store like one
of those kinds
you know like that's a [ __ ]
corruption
he's the kind of guy he gets out of he
gets out of this van he has this like
electric door he gets he gets into this
like little wheelchair he has to like
get lifted all the way this guy's an
[ __ ] this guy's a ramp everywhere
he takes so long to get in his
wheelchair and he's like complaining
because there's no ramps and we're like
nobody needs a ramp you know he goes to
those like just you dude gift shop type
stores that sell like car air fresheners
and he buys all the accessories like
that
this fool is like he's the kind of he's
the kind of guy that like this will
faint when he sees a cat or something
and his wife will pick him up like this
and bring him home and [ __ ] like he's a
damsel in distress too yeah
no my dog i remember he would be doing
laundry because i lived with him a
little bit too i would be doing laundry
and this i mean he'll be doing laundry
and then i had a little chihuahua that
would come out and then the chihuahua
would be like whoa whoa whoa whoa and
he's
and i'm like what the [ __ ] dude that's a
little dog like he'll bring the laundry
because the laundry machine is on the
back so he'll bring it and then like he
opens the metal gate
and he's like looking for the killer
chihuahua yeah and as soon as he sees
him he slams the gate drops his laundry
like a [ __ ] cartoon character and
then runs back and calls bart and leaves
the [ __ ] laundry thing what a [ __ ]
weirdo yeah but these are very minor
infractions yeah this guy's just like
timid dude yeah he just he just he
probably has some trauma he apparently
needs [ __ ] smeared on his car though for
this all of these crimes i don't know
who's doing it it's bart doing it has
been smearing [ __ ] the whole time like
he was there's communication in your car
he does have a weird rear-view mirror
he is kind of a nerd she should have
went to sanrio recently probably said he
probably said something is like someone
walking their dog one day and he was
like are you gonna pick that up and then
they were like yeah i'm gonna pick one
guarantee yeah i'm gonna pick it up yeah
i'm gonna pick it up every day
all right so this article is basically
about how they're bragging about their
[ __ ] dog dog food it's like better
for your dog stool and all kinds of [ __ ]
so i could get back to it but really
it's not as interesting as somebody
wants to pay you to [ __ ] sit there
and smell poop six g's though that's
what they gave somebody who an owner who
was dedicated to actually sit there they
got they're getting six thousand six
hundred eighty five dollars to use their
food dog food for two months and then
you have to
every time is vegan dog food though
aren't they omnivores or whatever
dog do you need to record yourself doing
it because what if you just [ __ ] lie
yeah dude that's what i would do that's
what i would do too for my science fair
experiment what was your science
experiment it was the the effects of
gingko blow bomb mice i did it for like
three days and [ __ ] forged all the
rest of the data i did that too
that's how you do a real science
experiment global advice yeah i was like
does it affect their memory and then i
got really bored of it really fast so
what what was your conclusion that you
forged i said sure i said sure
we need more studies to find out that's
what it was i met one of these parents
at titus jujitsu and they told me uh
red dragon karate if you
if you go home and you
certify that your kid has practiced for
however many hours they'll advance them
belts too so you can go to class maybe
like like once a week
but then if you're like i swear i saw
him train 20 hours this week they'll be
like here's your next belt no way wow
because kids love to train i think
they're just like college application
patterns
so i was like oh i have no idea how i
got a purple belt and take one down
karate does that you having a like a a
black belt in red dragon karate does
that help you get into universal not
anymore but it should before probably
they like extracurricular helps you get
into the kumite well it used to be it
used to be you could get a belt but now
they'll just [ __ ] take it away from
you i guess even if you start a little
tiny war oh
a little tiny you took two belts away
from him but judah wanted to take one
honorary judo and taekwondo that's
[ __ ] up man he's no longer a master of
sport i just don't know how someone can
get an honorary black belt like i
thought you had to earn one oh he's not
even a real black belt it says honorary
black belt type that's lame bro so i'm
like how do you get one but he's a judo
guide me i heard
but who's gonna who's gonna let him not
be a judo guy that's true it was uh he
was given to a at an honorary judo
studio he created
did you guys see the clip of uh like him
and conor taking a picture and connor's
like yeah yeah and then you see the uh
bodyguard guys like this and you see
connolly
arm over him like but i guess you can't
touch the god of the king
putin's allowed to he could touch
anybody once he [ __ ] grabbed all the
balls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you